I want to begin with something that
Churchill wrote in the 19 thirties and
he said this,
one of the signs of a great society uses
a diligence with which it passes culture
from one generation to the next.
When one generation no longer passages
on the things that are dear to it,
its heroes and they stories and its
religious faith.
It's in effect saying that past is not
void.
It's of no value.
He goes on to say that leaves young
people feeling a lack of direction and a
lack of purpose and opens them to the
dictum of Karl Marx that are people
derived of the history,
easily persuaded.
Have we stripped down young people have
purpose and meaning and left them open
to being bullied around whether there's
two things about that that I think are
really worth worth laying out.
The for the first is an analysis of the
purpose of memory.
Now because people think that the
purpose of memory is to remember the
past and that's not the purpose of
memory.
The purpose of memory is to extract out
from the past lessons to structure the
future,
and that's the purpose of personal
memory and so you're done with a memory
when you've extracted out the
information that you can use to guide
yourself properly in the future.
So if you have a traumatic memory,
for example,
that's really obsessing you.
If you analyze that memory to the point
where you figured out how you put
yourself at risk and you can determine
how you might avoid that in the future,
then the emotion associated with that
goes away.
So memories are has a very pragmatic
function and cultural memories.
The same thing is that we need to
extract out stories from our past that
structure our future and we need that
because first of all,
if you don't have a purpose,
let's say it isn't,
that your life becomes neutral in a in a
meaningless sentence.
It's that your life becomes
characterized by unbearable suffering
because the baseline condition of life
is something like unbearable suffering
and what you have to set against that is
a noble and worthwhile purpose and
hopefully,
hopefully your determination of that
purpose is buttress to some degree by
the wisdom of the past because you can't
conjure something like that up on your
own,
and if you provide people with nobility
of purpose,
then they can tolerate the suffering of
existence without becoming entirely
corrupted by it.
And cultures that don't do that,
it isn't even so much that they die.
It's that cultures that don't do that
are dead.
They're done.
They don't have a story anymore and they
don't have a call to adventure.
And then while then everyone suffers
stupidly.
As a consequence.
It's a very bad thing.
So Churchill made the same observation
that many of the great psychologists and
philosophers made in the early part of
the 20th century.
It's like bringing this story forward
and and propagate it and make it the
most noble possible story.
And then you motivate people to do,
to transcend themselves,
which they need to do.
So yes,
he's exactly right in his diagnosis.